el presidente ruso vladimir putin ha
invitado a los ministros de exteriores
de azerbaiyán y de armenia aquí a moscú
para mantener conversaciones que por lo
menos deriven en un alto el fuego en
nagorno karabaj o una zona donde siguen
los combates después de 11 días de
escalada bélica tanto la parte armenia
como la parte azerbaiyana se han
mostrado dispuestas a participar en
estas conversaciones que podrían servir
por lo menos para que durante un tiempo
de no enfrentamientos ambas partes
pudiesen intercambiar los cadáveres de
algunos soldados fallecidos que sabemos
que son cientos y también para
intercambiar prisioneros de guerra la
zona de nagorno karabaj es disputada
entre armenios y azerbaiyanos azerbaiyán
insiste en defender su integridad
territorial y armenia recuerda que en
qara bagh hay una mayoría armenia que
tiene derecho a la autodeterminación